hello everybody and welcome to episode
number seven of my road to oneill Series
today we're going to be starting off at
about 3.5 mil uh once I sell these grimy
rars anyway and yeah the focus of this
episode is not going to be really
anything uh not that it ever is but uh
we're going to definitely train our
Slayer and our range and we're going to
make some more money all right let's get
started okay so we're here at the Green
dragons uh we're just about to hit a
range level uh we generally don't come
here unless it's pretty late at night
but we didn't have much experience left
so they're 67 range and yeah we're going
to go for 200 Green Dragon kills okay
I'm actually an idiot I forgot to
upgrade to the red dragon hide about
seven levels ago uh so we'll claim this
uh offer in our offer slot for another
1.7 mil and we'll upgrade to Red Dragon
hide okay so there we go we have all the
red dragon hide let's see what our range
bonus was
151 and now it
is 160 so that's actually pretty
substantial difference that was
definitely a pretty decent mistake but
anyway uh let's continue on okay so we
actually have a clue scroll here that we
got from the green dragon so hopefully
we can go do it and we'll try to start
that as well okay so we are training
magic now and uh you might be wondering
what happened to that clue and I just
got [__] deleted when I went to the
Wilderness by those Dark Knights In The
Dark Knight Fortress uh there's like 10
of them multi combat they just destroyed
me I didn't have protect fore um yet so
we're going to have to get another three
prayer levels before we even try that so
yeah we're going to go for 50 magic here
just by
splashing uh cuz I have to do some work
today and I this is pretty easy okay so
we're at 45 magic uh another five magic
levels I think we have the runes so we
should get there pretty soon I mean it's
only 14k experience an hour splashing
but you know it's something and uh we'll
come back when we're level
50 okay there is 50 magic um it is kind
of just an arbitrary number there's
nothing I get at 50 that's that
important uh but we want to get it up to
70 75 to do Zer at some point and it's
just kind of nice to have it up there uh
so next I think we're going to do a bit
of Slayer we kind of want to chip away
at that and I know it's not the most
efficient right now um but it's kind of
nice to kind of slowly do it okay so
here we're doing our first Slayer task
we're at banshees um which isn't too bad
uh oh no I forgot my ear muffs
ah okay so we're back and O those ear
muffs actually look pretty nice I might
continue wearing those uh but Banshee is
not too bad and we'll finish this task
quickly okay there is 35 Slayer as well
uh we can now kill wall Beast H I wish I
didn't have to okay so we just finished
up our last task and now we have
otherworldly beans uh those actually
pretty good considering there's a bunch
of crap that B can assign you so I'm
kind of happy with that okay so yeah
these guys are actually really not too
bad they kind of hit kind of hard and I
know they they are weak to Magic but
there 36 Slayer and yeah pretty decent
experience for range as well okay there
our task is completed um took probably
half an hour or something um so yeah I
wouldn't mind having these guys again
really not too bad okay so let's get our
task and see what we get next and it's
going to be 17 vampires H it's not very
good but it'll only take me a minute to
do so we'll go kill the vampires quickly
okay so we're in cannabis killing the
vampires um there's level 67 ones and
level 51 or something there's some that
are weaker these ones are a stronger one
back uh but yeah there we go we've
gotten 20 points for finish our 10th
task in a row so not bad okay so let's
see again what we're going to get for a
Slayer task and more other wieldly beans
um see again not too happy or I am
pretty happy with that uh considering
there's a bunch of crap that you can get
so we'll go do those quickly okay we're
back at these uh otherworldly beans kind
of hard to say actually and there is 38
Slayer uh working our way there only uh
17 more Slayer levels till broad
bolts okay there's level 39 Slayer um so
these guys again are pretty good
experience as well now we can kill
manans mollusks I don't even know what
that said uh yeah we're almost done the
task and we'll probably grab another one
after okay let's see what we
get oh what oh [__] I didn't kill one of
them my God okay so we're back we killed
the last bean and we got desert lizards
again that's not my favorite
uh luckily it doesn't take too long but
I really don't want to do
that okay so if you have uh watched my
other video May notice this already I've
done this uh but this is the compost
potion uh money-making method that I did
in my other video I just did on this
account because I mean this is my road
to one bill account there's no reason
for me to do on a separate account uh so
yeah what again if you didn't see that
video what we're doing is we're going to
be buying compost potions and we're
going to be using them on regular
compost to turn them into Super compost
uh as you can see here we've bought five
00 so far uh it took a couple days to
buy um and the compost bought pretty
quickly though and all we're going to do
is use each individual dose on each
compost it's going to be a bit timec
consuming and going to hurt my hand but
it's pretty good money and uh if you
watch the video you know I made quite a
bit in the 1 hour of doing this so again
I'll just show you quickly what you do
if you did not see the video
or I don't know if you don't want to
watch it so yeah all you have to do is
withdraw five Super compost or compost
potions sorry uh the rest compost and
then you're just going to use them on
the compost just like this nothing fancy
to it and yeah we'll come back when we
have actually used all these
potions okay so we're just finishing up
the last inventory of the super compost
um this is the quickest way to do it uh
if you didn't see the video you just
kind of drag it down to the bottom
corner uh spam click them together and
then it'll fly off and then just bring
it back it's pretty easy I can do about
600 in an hour uh 500 if you're not
paying attention too much and yeah so it
took me about 1 hour to do all these uh
turn the compost into Super compost and
yeah we'll sell them and see how much we
actually made okay so we're going to
start by selling them for
97 uh the high price and then maybe
we'll move it down if we don't sell them
quickly uh but assuming we sold them all
for the high price we'd get about 1.2
milon profit which is awesome I
definitely recommend this and if you
haven't seen the video just go check it
out and yeah we'll come back when they
have sold okay so we ended up selling
them actually for the low price cuz we
got a little impatient um but still
that's 1.1 million profit it was awful
clicking them together to be honest but
luckily these potions don't buy too
quickly so you won't actually be stuck
doing a ton of potions and now that I
released the video there's going to be
more people buying them so yeah just if
you want to leave an offer in it's not a
bad idea even if you buy 100 of these
couple hundred still make a good amount
of money so I'm just going to leave an
offer in after this and yeah we'll just
calculate how much we made so 1712 minus
uh 600 uh minus another 50 for the
compost potions about leav us at about
1.1 mil so that's really awesome okay
we're just finishing up another Farm run
um we did another 40 seeds and again
this Tak me about uh two days on average
to do uh 40 seeds gives me about 900k to
1 milon profit every time so pretty
awesome so there we go just finished up
our run so we'll see how much we
actually have in the bank from this uh
Farm run uh we got about 32 from that
actual physical run and we got about
238 which is pretty average uh so pretty
nice and we'll go ahead and sell those
okay so we're going to pop those in for
about 7.1k or something and that will
actually bring us up to about 5 mil uh
which is pretty sweet uh once we claim
it anyway uh so we'll actually be able
to afford I might might get a cannon at
some point uh but we'll see so we'll go
ahead and buy some more Runar seeds as
well and I think we might actually put
an offer for the compost potion as well
um because it was awesome awesome way to
make money and it I don't know it's just
gonna go up from here so I might as well
just put an offer in while we have the
chance yeah see 1300 let's see what we
sell it for though uh 825 actually yeah
that's pretty good so we'll just put an
offer in for 825 and see how many we
manage to buy and we'll just leave it in
for a week like who knows it could take
a while but it's not using a whole lot
of our money okay so we're just kind of
finishing up our task at the desert
lizards um it's not a very good task so
I think I might block it uh but what do
you guys think do you think I should
block tasks spend my points on Slayer
Rings which I was kind of leaning
towards
um or the Slayer helmet what do you
think I should spend my points on I'm
kind of leaning towards the Slayer Rings
because it offers teleportation they
useful outside of Slayer um but I would
need 75 crafting and that would be
expensive and timec consuming uh well
it' be expensive or timec consuming
pretty much uh so yeah I'm a little
undecided about that so I'm just going
to save my points until I kind of figure
out what I want to do uh but we're
actually just about to hit a range level
here as well as finish the task so
pretty good timing hopefully we can hit
70 by the end of the episode but I'm
getting kind of tired and uh I kind of
want to put this episode out
today and yeah there is level 69 range
it we'll finish up the task and grab a
new one okay let's see what we get and
it's 20 cave bugs that is pretty awful
but pretty good for the points I guess
so we'll kind of go knocked out of the
way quickly okay so we did finish that
quickly and we got cockatrices that's
definitely better so it's actually some
decent experience but I don't know if
we're going to do that right
now um um yeah I think we're going to go
sell some of our drops so we have slowly
uh but surely been killing dragons over
this last week usually when it's late at
night so we've hit about 200 Dragon
kills mind you were missing seven dragon
bones but that was when I was running
away from a PK and I was just kind of
spite burying them all CU I thought I
was going to die but ended up not dying
but either way we're going to get about
1 mil from the dragon bones and the
dragon hides as well as another 900k
from the grimards that we just sold and
that's actually going to bring our cash
deck up to about uh 5 mil so I think we
might end up purchasing the cannon uh
but first we have to do the giant dwarf
Quest okay so we're off to just start
the quest it's a really easy one doesn't
really have any requirements and yeah
we'll just knock this out the way
quickly okay so there we are we're done
the quest only took about 20 minutes um
just had to do a little bit of running
around and now we have access to the uh
dwarf Cannon which is pretty awesome
it's just an awesome tool for Slayer
range training in total and yeah we'll
go ahead and buy one okay so I don't
actually remember how much they are but
it looks like they are 800k so we bought
one dwar dwarf Cannon some dwarf cannon
balls uh some ranging potions and some
stamina potions and our plan is to
actually just go do some more green
dragons but with the cannon instead so
we're going to see how effective this
ends up being because I've heard it's
actually pretty good money uh so we're
going to go probably to the closer spot
that I've been at uh this last couple
weeks cuz it's safer but eventually I
think I'm going to go to the deeper
Wilderness cuz it's quicker surprisingly
okay so we're going to pop our Canon
down here H it looks like there's a guy
here actually so we'll probably hop
worlds not going to be that guy to just
pop down the cannon and piss everyone
off so we'll switch World okay this
world looks like it's free uh so we'll
pop down the cannon right here and I
think the plan is to just run around
with a stamina potion uh while the
cannon kills it for you because it is
multi combat so it will only attack all
the dragons if I'm not in combat
currently and yeah we're going to see
how this works and um I've heard you can
get upwards of 800 900k an hour all
right guys I think that's what we're
going to call it for today uh we made a
good amount of progress this episode we
got our range level up uh we got a dwarf
Cannon we got our magic level up
um and yeah if you're enjoying the
series please leave the video like as
always and stay subscribed to see when
the next video is out all right I will
see you guys next time
[Music]